gas prices are high right now you don't
need me to tell you that you know we
know it's having a major impact so we've
started a campaign in cooperation with
conoco to help gift you a good day let's
take a look at how i surprised one lucky
customer and gifted him a very good day
i met curtis at the conoco on east lake
me how much have you noticed gas prices
going up quite a bit curtis is a
delivery driver so he's feeling the pain
of the pump it hurts me
because i'm feeling up three to four
times a week spending about 300 to 350 a
week in gas because of the increased
prices he's had to make some major
changes what are you having to cut back
on
foods i've been eating at work a lot
more
stuff at home bills i went down on my
phone bill to do that too
and if i'm not at work i'm staying at
home pretty much because of the gas i
also found out curtis has a surprise on
the way you found it you're going to be
at a dad yesterday yesterday yeah wow
yesterday now it was time to gift this
new dad a good day well you're in luck
channel 8 here we are trying to gift
people a good day and with conica we're
going to help people out so we'd like to
help pay your gas what do you say sounds
good with me give you a bit of a helping
hand is that cool all right man i
appreciate it
here it is
gifting you a good day love you
appreciate it
one day i'll figure that whole gifting
thing out but he was very appreciative
had a great time surprising curtis don't
forget you never know when you could be
next yeah curtis was full of surprises
he
told us he's going to be a father he
found out the day before we caught up
with him he's going to be a dad
and he mentioned how he eats at work
he's a delivery driver for a pizza
company in town so he has sort of an old
uh dodge uh suv
and those things are gas guzzlers but
you can't just sort of like change your
car like that right so you're kind of
stuck with what you've got so he has to
fill his gas tank a lot and he used all
the money that we we gave him we gifted
him he put it all in there he filled up
right to the brim
it